[MUSIC PLAYING]
WESLEY CHUN: Hi.
This is Wesley Chun,
engineer here at Google.
Today we're going
to show you how
to do something
you've never been
able to do before-- format
spreadsheet cells using Google
Sheets API.
Yeah, that's right.
You couldn't do this
in older API releases.
And I've got a stack of Stack
Overflow questions to prove it.
So I hope you're
excited as I am.
To keep it short
and sweet, I won't
be discussing reading or writing
a Sheet, nor import export.
Those are covered in other
episodes, one of which
is where we show you how to
migrate toy orders from a SQL
database to a Google Sheet.
We're going to reuse the same
Sheet created in that video.
So check it out and
run that script first.
Check out the Sheet
that it's created.
Doesn't that look totally bland?
Well, today you're
going to learn
how to format those cells
to make it more presentable.
What do you think?
Way better, right?
To get the sheet
to look like this,
you have to send formatting
commands to the API.
For this sample, there are four.
One, freeze the top row.
Two, bold the top row.
Three, format the prices in
column E as financial values.
And then lastly, adding
a fixed values and cell
validation for the order
status in column F.
What do those
commands look like?
Well, each request is a JSON
structure represented here
in this pseudo code as
a Python dictionary.
You can group as many of them
as desired into an array,
like a Python list, and
send them together in one
API call to
spreadsheets.batchUpdate.
Let's look at each of the
four requests for our Sheet
now, but more generically
in JavaScript.
Frozen rows are
a Sheet property.
So we need a command that
updates Sheet properties.
After much research
we decided to name
it updateSheetProperties.
More specifically, set the
frozen row count attribute
of a Sheet's grid
properties to freeze
the top n rows of the sheet.
For us, n is one.
Before moving on
let's talk about Sheet
ranges because we need them
for the remaining requests.
First, a range is made up
of a Sheet ID and indexes.
Next, when you create a
brand new spreadsheet,
the default Sheet that's created
for you has an ID of zero.
Like most programming
languages, counting
starts at zero, not one.
So here, you can see column
names and row numbers
and mentally convert them
to zero-based indexes.
Also, ranges are exclusive
of all end indexes.
That means that they
go up to but do not
include the end index value.
Lastly, know that
you can leave out
an index when you want
to take the default.
We'll discuss each
situation as it comes up.
Time for a quiz.
See the blue highlighted
range in the Sheet?
Now, this range JSON
object you see here?
Well, what should we
fill in for each value?
We'll start with the
Sheet ID, assuming
this is the default Sheet.
That's right.
The ID is 0.
In fact, if you know you're
accessing this default Sheet,
you can leave out the
Sheet ID completely.
The range starts at column D,
which is at index zero, one,
two, three.
It ends at column
E, which is four.
But since the end
index is excluded,
we need to bump that up to five.
Similarly, the starting row is
three, but that's at index two.
Finally, it ends at row
four, which is at three.
But we need to bump
that up to four.
Good job.
Now you know how
to set up ranges.
To see more examples and
learn more about grid ranges,
see the documentation.
Now we can talk about
the other three requests,
starting with bolding
that frozen row.
The verb is repeat cell,
meaning apply this format
to all cells in a
given range, which
is the first row
in the first Sheet.
Now that you know
all about ranges,
you can see that these are the
correct values representing
the first row.
However, we recommend you
drop both column indexes.
Hard coding columns
is a bad idea
because if you add more columns
they're not going to be bolded.
By leaving them
out the entire row
will be bolded, regardless
of the number of columns.
If you're accessing
the first default
Sheet, meaning its
ID is zero, you
can leave off the Sheet ID too.
Finally, all start
indices default to zero,
so we can also drop
start row index.
The only one you really
need is endRowIndex.
Next is what you want
changed in the cells.
In our case, it's
the textFormat.
Specifically, its bold
property, toggling it to True.
Finally, Fields specifies
which field should be effected.
Think of it like a
bitmask or a field mask.
Here we don't want to
change any existing
formatting other than
the cell's bold setting.
For example, if you only had
user entered format without
the .textFormat.bold
as your Fields element,
you're going to lose things like
the cell's background color,
the vertical alignment,
and other properties.
Check our docs to see
other formatting examples,
as well as to find out
more about field masks.
Now let's format the toy unit
costs in column E. For range,
I left off the Sheet ID
because we know it's zero.
We're formatting
rows two through six,
meaning start and end
indexes of one and six.
But we should drop the
endRowIndex for the same reason
as described before-- to
bold all of the first row.
Instead of omitting
the endColumnIndex,
we leave off the
endRowIndex so as to format
the rest of the column,
even if new rows are added.
Column E indexes are four and
five, and both are needed.
Now, we're changing the
user entered format also.
But this time, it's number
format instead of text format,
giving the US Dollar
currency format
with a dollar sign, comma
separated thousands, and two
decimal places.
The Fields mask is what
you expect, changing only
the cell's number format.
Getting easier?
All right.
More on date, time,
and number formats
can be found in
the documentation.
The last formatting request
is setDataValidation,
adding fixed fields for
toy order status and cell
validation of those values.
Range is as before,
but now for column F.
As before, we want to
format the entire column so
leave off the endRowIndex.
The rule is that the
cell should or must
contain one of a list
of valid values pending
shipped or delivered.
Should means weak
enforcement, while must
is strict enforcement.
That means that if a user enters
something other than these,
you'll get an alert like this.
Enforcement is controlled by
the strict variable, which
if you omit defaults to
false, which we did here
and in the Python script.
Use the inputMessage attribute
if you want a custom message
when users go to the cell.
It's not important to
me, so I'm leaving it
out using the system default.
If you choose strict
enforcement with inputMessage
set to what we have
here and uncommented,
users will get this message.
If you take the
default, like I did,
users will get this
dialog text instead.
The showCustomUi flag causes
a pull-down list of options
to be displayed.
Now, it's a pretty poor
experience without it
because users are
not going to know
what available choices
are, so I recommend
you always use it too.
OK, that's it.
Now you know how to format cells
using the Google Sheets API.
For a change, we won't
be going to the computer
today since constructing
the JSON payload makes up
most of our short,
70-line Python script.
If you take a look at
the code deep dive,
you can confirm that,
other than the boilerplate
and a single call to the
API, all the heavy lifting
is done in constructing
these four requests, which
consist of a Python
list of dictionaries.
Check out the first link to
see more on JSON payloads,
specifically common operations
that you will do with the API.
The second link takes
you to the Sheets API
concepts, quickstarts, and other
guides to help you get started.
The last link takes you
directly to the reference docs.
Once you get this sample working
and want another challenge,
use the API to create a
Column G with the total cost
header in cell G1.
Set the cell G2 with
the formula to calculate
the costs based on the toys
ordered and cost in columns D
and E. And then use the
Autofill command to copy
that formula down Column
G. Hint-- you only
need the range attribute.
More on this challenge
in the code review post
mentioned earlier.
We hope you learned a lot about
formatting with the Sheets
API in this video
and have gotten
a taste of how
much more powerful
this API is compared
to previous versions.
Now you can build
those awesome apps
that you weren't able
to do in the past.
This is Wesley Chun
from Google reminding
you to subscribe to our channel
and leave any comments below.
Have fun with the Sheets API
and we'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]